el precio del cambio climático las altas
temperaturas han agravado los más de 70
incendios activos en el oeste
norteamericano desde canadá hasta eeuu
de oregón a california pasando por
washington y montana la ola de calor y
las sequías han avivado las llamas que
han devastado más de 38 mil hectáreas
[Música]
el comportamiento del fuego es
impredecible por lo que hay varios
aspectos un montón de variantes que
entran en juego tienes el clima el
terreno los combustibles la humedad hay
varias cosas que juegan en efecto allí
ser salvo de sanxenxo
la situación más grave se vive en el
estado de oregón donde el denominado but
lak fire el mayor incendio forestal que
arde en el país ha calcinado una
superficie superior al distrito de nueva
york y amenaza unas 2000 estructuras más
de 1300 personas han sido evacuadas
otros tuvieron que salir apresuradamente
recogimos lo que pudimos cogimos los
gatos y el fuego estaba allí mismo se
podía oír el rugido era como un tren de
carga y las llamas venían hacia nosotros
el humo era horrible así que subimos a
nuestros vehículos y salimos pitando no
olvidemos
más del 60 por ciento del oeste de eeuu
sufrió una sequía extrema con récords de
temperaturas históricos que dificultan
el trabajo de los bomberos mientras los
expertos alarman de una nueva ola de
calor